vas-y Benjamin il connaît déjà
extrêmement pour ce chat mais
effectivement on va pas on va pas
retarder un chien pour un train pour un
chat je suis désolé je suis désolé il
faut arrêter des conneries on doit pas
faire quoi on doit pas avoir rendez-vous
le train pour en avance sur le chat
coupe le champ en deux a-t-il
moi si j'ai un rendez-vous ce qu'il a
dit si j'ai un rendez-vous 20 minutes
après qu'on ne retape pas mon train
qu'on coupe le champ en deux il a dit ça
[Applaudissements]
eux c'est horrible écoute c'est un chat
et c'est tout le monde c'est du retard
pourquoi
il fait quoi voilà mon chien je dois
être tenues
la question qu'on vous propose un
amateur 12 en direct Benjamin Castaldi
est-il allé trop loin bien sûr mais
c'est normal que vous disiez non
est avec nos crisières mais bonsoir
merci d'être là vous êtes amis des chats
vous êtes artiste animaliste président
d'une association qui s'occupe des
animaux et des personnes sans domicile
fixes d'accord et vous et on a alors que
c'est David qui est avec nous qui lui
aussi a été très énervé parce qu'il a
dit Benjamin Castaldi hier est-ce que
vous pouvez répéter Gilles devant
Grisière et David le scadi benjamin
Castillet on loge qu'il a redit parce
que vous pouvez le redire moi je redis
alors je disais
le drame qui a convaincu les
propriétaires du chat mais effectivement
je suis désolé ça y est non non non
je suis désolé on ne retarde pas un
train d'abord pour un chat pauvre chat
mais encore une fois on va on va mettre
en danger attendez
maintenant voilà ah oui là tu commences
à trembler t'es trop chafouin
et en plus vous avez été je vais vous
dire la vérité on serait on serait on
serait on avait intervenu il y a eu un
accident soit quelqu'un de la sécurité
soit un pompier
il aurait eu un problème je suis désolé
je dis c'est terrible j'éteindre
terrible pour le chat mais je suis
désolé on retarde pas il mange 400 600
voyageurs pour un chat et je et je
considère
une petite info mademoiselle il faut que
vous sachiez oui c'est que Benjamin m'a
dit horloge oui mais ce que tu sais pas
c'est que moi ça aurait été mon chien
j'aurais voulu qu'on le sauve mais bien
sûr il est où ton problème alors et bien
sûr
c'est pas ton chien tu le sens où
il a passé toute sa vie à sa gueule
le train
20 minutes c'est personne là Cyril ont
été voir les agents de la SNCF les
contrôleurs pendant 20 minutes ça a été
une inactivité il y a rien eu ils en ont
pas fait par l'arrière ils ont décidé de
même de dire les gens écoutaient vous
aviez qu'à mieux le tenir hier j'ai
entendu que le chat était dans un carton
c'est faux c'est damla elles ont payé 7
euros je sais plus combien pour que leur
chatte en sécurité il était dans une
caisse de transport qui s'est ouverte ça
veut dire qu'il y a eu un accès un
incident qui était tombé sur les voies
on aurait dit ah bah fallait lui tenir
mieux la main tant pis on sait rien
c'est très important à partir du moment
tu peux il a payé il est considéré comme
un passage désolé et qu'est-ce qu'on
aurait fait pour un passager
en deux pareil exactement
on peut rien faire on peut pas descendre
après apparemment après quand le chat
était mort et coupé en deux on leur a
proposé de descendre pour récupérer le
corps c'est-à-dire que quand il est
vivant on ne peut rien faire quand il
est mort on peut défendre
à partir du moment où il a payé mais
vous êtes fous quoi mais sérieux donc
payé pour le chat oui on peut mais allez
sauver quand on a payé c'est n'importe
quoi ça serait votre chien vous auriez
tout fait vous dites n'importe quoi même
s'il a pas payé mais ça rajoute en plus
parce que là je parle en termes de loi
voilà comme ici c'est vrai que c'est au
nom de la loi pour moi il a payé donc
c'est comme un passager
ce que vous pouvez faire en sondage en
direct le lancer sur Twitter là
forcément
ok super voilà d'ailleurs est-ce que
Benjamin Castaldi a été trop loin c'est
la question
[Rires]
excusez-moi excusez-moi c'est un drame
personnel terrible mais encore une fois
on va pas retarder 800 boules
à faire très attention c'est un passager
n'importe quoi évidemment quand elle est
sauvé moi monsieur et un enfant c'est
pas la même chose voilà
à porter plainte puisque la SNCF était
au courant pendant 20 minutes ils ont
rien fait pour acte de cruauté sur un
animal domestique 50 prisons 74
moi je demande parce que j'ai noté son
nom
c'est pas ça non non rien à voir le PDG
de la SNCF c'est ça
je sais plus comment
s'engage aujourd'hui à partir de
maintenant à former ses agents pour
qu'il y a un protocole quand il y a un
animal
les rats qu'on écrase tous les jours
alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire c'est
pas un animal de compagnie
je leur ai demandé
[Applaudissements]
elle a trois rats
il y a 80 millions d'animaux de
compagnie en France aujourd'hui soit un
franc un Français sur deux à un animal
de compagnie chez lui savoir que vous
avez craché la gueule d'un Français sur
200 déconner donc effectivement
et alors si vous voulez le problème
c'est que moi je pensais qu'on n'avait
pas le droit d'aller sur les voies on
n'a pas le droit d'aller sur les voies
mais parce que je pense que c'était
électrifié non et en fait c'est pas
l'électricité
vraiment on avait le temps d'aller
chercher ce pauvre chat ça c'est vrai
voilà alors en France il y a un problème
dans
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
malheureusement je le redis encore une
fois voilà on va pas on va pas
excusez-moi il y a 800 passagers il y a
800 personnes
il a pas vu que le cheval le train il
partait voilà déjà
arrivé
je mettrai jamais à une un humain et un
animaliers non mais le truc
c'est pas le chien
je vous dis voilà les gens qui ont
essayé
j'aimerais bien que la SNCF monsieur
Chabanel fasse un communiqué pour
s'excuser publiquement et garantir aux
usagers de la SNCF que si ramène leur
animal domestique il prendra pas un
allisme pour la mort en fait s'il vous
plaît alors qu'est-ce que tu dis de tout
ça après on aura David Benjamin je suis
content parce que ce soir le bourreau
est face à ses victimes
oh la manière dont vous traitez avec
désinvolture ce chat ce que vous avez
dit en loge oui alors il est arrivé
plein de fortes rentrés et tout ça j'en
ai rien à faire lâchement avec ton
affaire de chat avec un trait d'humour
débile il y a pas de quoi fouetter un
chat mais ça c'est sympa
c'est pas bien ce que vous avez fait
franchement vous devriez honnêtement
avant que ça prenne trop d'ampleur vous
devriez vous excuser on ne tue pas
impunément un charme ne le coupe pas en
deux au pied d'un train Benjamin
castaldiments à ça arrêtez arrêtez au
contrôle
je peux pas dire qui c'est qui travaille
à la SNCF et il a il me dit en fait la
SNCF a calculé il m'a dit ils vont payer
pour les dommages insérer pour ça mais
ils m'ont dit je préfère donner euh
15000 euros je sais pas combien de
dommages d'intérêt que de rembourser des
billets des voyageurs en retard risque
calculés
donc la vie d'un chat en fait ça vaut
une indemnisation SNCF c'est ça le
problème
pour les personnes en janvier bonne
année salut et donc Géraldine tu sais
qu'on hiérarchiser les espèces mais
c'est vous qui le fait clairement vous
dites clairement que l'être humain c'est
important non vous dites que l'être
humain c'est important et les animaux on
s'en fout complètement je considère
et plus important que l'animal donc un
retard SNCF de 20 minutes c'est
important qu'un animal meurt on s'en
fout non on s'en fout
c'est ce que vous dites-moi traumatisant
on s'en fout en règle voilà donc
évidemment c'est traumatisant mais
malgré tout je considère que c'est un
fait divers tragique
il y a aucune mesure de prise par
exemple le train aurait pu démarrer
extrêmement doucement ce qui fait parce
que ils prennent de la vitesse les
trains le chat ou le train il aurait pu
démarrer à deux trois à l'heure le chat
serait pas fait écrasé devant la gueule
ils ont pas démarrer à 200 alors mais
c'est pas ça le train le Train le chat
s'est fait écrabouiller par le dernier
wagon jusqu'au dernier wagon il allait
bien le dernier wagon prend de la
vitesse en sortie de Dodge le chat s'est
fait cramouiller donc voilà en fait
j'imagine aussi que le chat réagisse et
qu'ils sont mais il y a rien du
d'essayer Géraldine c'est ce que je vous
dis s'ils avaient fait quelque chose il
y avait même pas de retard il y avait 20
minutes pour essayer quelque chose il y
a rien le train n'a pas eu une minute de
retard pas une parce que pendant 20
minutes elles se sont acharnées à aller
voir Pierre Paul Jacques elles ont payé
7 € pour qu'on leur dise allez vous
faire vous avez payé maintenant
c'est fini votre chat il va se faire
écraser vous aviez quel tenir vous avez
ça c'est pas des excuses quand on a payé
on a une assurance croix dans le ticket
enfin bon voilà
je vous redis que les choses tout de
suite il y a évidemment évidemment c'est
un drame épouvantable et j'adore les
animaux et j'adore les chats je vous dis
que la SNCF la société de ta question
était la SNCF a-t-elle bien fait de
aller au bout de son horaire et donc
malheureusement de passer par-dessus le
chat je vous dis la SNCF elle a fait son
boulot de SNCF à partir
elle a dit oui les gens ils rentrent de
vacances ils ont pas que ça à faire des
entités
Jules alors ce que vous avez dit est
très important serrer parce que le
témoignage que vous avez eu si vraiment
l'enquête parce qu'il y aura une enquête
prouve que la SNCF a consciemment comme
sa préférée dire on va rembourser 15000
et pas payer les billets alors là mais
si jamais c'était vrai là c'est vraiment
l'acte de cruauté décision prise en
conscience effectivement la SNCF le PDG
de la SNCF pourrait prendre 50 prisons
et moi ce que je voudrais des conneries
arrête de dire des conneries toi tu es
toujours plus haut toi
c'est toujours plus haut dans la
connerie le gars il va arriver
50 prisons 75000
pour décorer pour les animaux les peines
elles ne tombent jamais même pas un mot
comme c'est quelqu'un qui plonge parce
qu'il a balancé son chat du haut de son
bâtiment qu'il a brûlé qu'il a laissé
crever des chiens là récemment il y a
des chiens qui sont qui ont été laissés
morts de faim on rend des animaux au
propriétaire on les condamne à 6 mois
sur 6 parce qu'ils ont déjà des
antécédents et c'est pour ça qu'ils vont
en prison qui prennent du ferme ou du
sursis c'est pas pour l'animal donc on
on a c'est voilà pardon était renforcés
c'est 5 ans avant c'était 3 ans mais
elles n'ont jamais été appliquée ses
doigts sont faites pour décorer ciel je
suis désolé c'est scandaleux vous vous
êtes mon de l'association seconde chance
c'est quoi votre association vous êtes
dans vos on voulait encore vous aussi à
Benjamin Castaldi carrément
alors seconde chance c'est une
association dont l'objectif est de
trouver des familles d'accueil
donc c'est une association qui a pour
objectif
je sais pas ce qu'il y a de marron mais
bon
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez réfléchi s'en
charger
trois fois ou quatre fois je redis ce
que c'est terrible et pour la maman et
pour la petite fille c'est un truc et
épouvantable évidemment on parle pas de
ça je vous dis encore une fois que 1 je
vous dis franchement il y a des choses
en ce moment bien plus grave que cette
histoire déjà pour commencer
d'accord très bien et je vous redis
malheureusement que c'est comme ça c'est
tragique mais c'est comme ça
effectivement ils ont préféré ne pas
mettre en retard ce train et je
comprends que la SNCF va pas faire un
procès et mettre le patron la SNCF en
tôle avec 50 tôles parce qu'il y a eu un
un parce qu'il y avait un chasse aux
sources
malheureusement dans la vie
malheureusement
je suis choqué évidemment c'est normal
je comprends que vous êtes choqué hein
mais moi mais moi je me suis choqué
en le disant je n'ai plus regrette pas
l'air choqué
il est parfaitement compris de la SNCF
et s'il fallait le refaire il couperait
le chat en deux Benjamin merci tu vois
comme d'habitude
et malheureusement tes deux lobes de
cerveau ne connectent plus donc
tu es complètement sclérosé et l'autre
techniquement abondamment
abruti je veux dire même tout à l'heure
je t'ai vu tout à l'heure en train de
dire des tu rigoles sur ça tu rigoles
mais arrêtez mais arrêtez monsieur la
mort de l'être humain prenez des
postures la mort d'un être
humains en Ukraine veulent me faire
chier qu'un chat maintenant ça te fait
des animaux par exemple je parle avec
Bernard il y a 2 secondes qui a eu un
chien qui a qui a beaucoup aimé et qui a
encore 10 ans après s'en souvient avec
l'alarme
deuxièmement vous insultez ces deux
personnes là ce sont la gamine elle a vu
le chat coupé en rouge
c'est un drame épouvantable et je me
compatis à 2000% après je vous place
d'un lieu de voir d'un point de vue de
la SNCF la
sncfecture
parce qu'il en prend plein la gueule
il pourrait dire bonjour
je comprends très bien franchement je
vous le dis franchement après voilà une
des façons de d'aller plus loin par
rapport à un drame c'est aussi l'humour
vous ne savez pas mais si c'est vrai moi
comme ça parfois vous avez compris mais
arrêtez votre posture monsieur
vous avez une posture là franchement
un animal en fait on dit que les animaux
n'ont pas de voix c'est pas qu'ils ont
pas de voix c'est que personne n'est
représente en fait ils ont pas trouvé
économique le seul pouvoir économique
c'est les gens qui les aiment cachent à
manger pour eux et qui paye les
vétérinaires et nous on a un pouvoir
économique et nous on est leur voix aux
animaux
oui vous avez raison vous avez raison
voilà je vous parle de la SNCF c'est la
question de départ j'ai pas dit oui je
vais couper le chat quand vous avez
entendu cette histoire
vous étiez triste comme nous
par rapport au chat vous voulez dire par
rapport à la SNCF déjà moi ça fait quoi
mon histoire personnelle
[Musique]
moi j'ai deux chats
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de marron
c'est des prénoms en fait moi le
problème c'est que le mois dernier mon
chat chouquette
c'est enfui et se faire renverser par un
premier
débat moi je suis sur Internet
et donc du coup quand j'ai non mais je
dis ça c'est pas pour ça c'est parce
qu'en fait j'ai une communauté qui a
réagi quand j'ai dit que je passais ce
soir et donc j'ai eu des témoignages de
gens donc des dizaines c'est pour ça que
je dis il est donc à une femme pareil
qu'à son chien qui s'est la laisse s'est
cassé et le chien et le train rouge sur
le chien non mais c'est pas drôle en
fait parce que là les gens ils ont
encore une fois payé un ticket
on fait payer un ticket après on s'en
fout du truc
voilà mais sinon le monsieur il a perdu
son chat
il s'est fait non non mais c'est bon non
mais vous
j'ai entendu parler j'étais en train de
penser me dire mais comment 2023 on peut
parler encore comme ça à la télé en plus
alors que maintenant on sait on sait que
les animaux ressentent des sentiments
sont émotif
c'est un appel au crime c'est l'apologie
au crime l'apologie
[Rires]
ok c'est tout oui c'est tout ouais
alors désolé mais toutes les réactions
à la maison donc je pense pas que voilà
que les gens sont indifférents merci bon
bah merci David en tout cas d'avoir été
avec nous dans Monsieur
[Applaudissements]
merci David crazy merci David merci
d'avoir été là merci c'est bon merci
merci
[Applaudissements]